get it together get it it's been a while
you're not together happy new year
well by the time this publishes it'll
still just kidding but new year it is
already 2017 s that's impossible Mike
hey guys welcome we are still playing
Resident Evil 3 it is close to our
deadline January for Resident Evil 7
four games to go here we go
whatever we'll just be playing seven and
after no one wants to watch you play it
before they play it so we're giving
everybody we did this on purpose to give
buddy a chance to play it before they
watch you play um help me through what
happened last time I don't watch our
show okay I'm just kidding I finished a
puzzle that was real annoying what the
pressure one
and yes and I saved again because I knew
I was gonna frickin die and I did uh to
the Nemesis what she did okay and now
I'm back and I gotta fight him again and
I remember it's the one with the pipes
in the acid and you got the pipes and
get the acid to fall on them and all the
users were like dum dum you got to use
our two to shoot the pipes and our one
to shoot him so I need to like
specifically only use our two to shoot
the pipes so I'm going to try that this
is our to focus on like environmental
environmental things it makes sense it's
it's all sound logic I'm just upset I
played this game a while well I'm just
not good at this game apparently but I
tried entertaining for me and for
everybody watching okay I did not have
this much problems with re one and two
this one makes me feel really bad about
myself I don't think this is nearly as
good of a game as re one two well oh I
forgot I forgot about all right I
actually totally forgot that this rain
Davos
so I need to use our one totally no
worries got it suck it
what that's [ __ ] [ __ ] I got
[ __ ] hurt from that yeah there's
another one up here
good achieved it last time so distraught
from that she's doesn't care anymore run
I act like you've been there before
intentional meanwhile just green jealous
spewing out of his thighs no no no I
want these Shogun shells and then I
thought maybe there was health but
there's probably not attentive viewers
my nose we're in a new studio we switch
rooms we did this one is a little higher
quality than you're used to
wow that's the kind of quality you can
come to expect from a GameSpot show the
video playing how dare you I would say
the quality and my skills are about on
par adequate par as good adequate is the
word I would use to define us what sauce
don't group me with you yeah it's too
late you work you work for this company
why not pride your country so do you
think I should heal now cuz I'm already
freaking hurt or die's gonna get away
with a couple couple whips probably get
away a couple Whippany booze [ __ ] can I
go down or up to get to the thingy no I
guess it's just a button well there you
go
so this is wait actually don't remember
anymore all right I think you're going
yeah that way I'm going towards that zom
into that room nice I think in previous
ones I shot him but I was all like
whatever oh yeah and then I have to go
through this cutscene remember yeah we
saw this twice las up Abed he's such an
obvious bad guy those massive bonus
appendages does not mean evil Donald
Trump's legs are so you have like skinny
old chicken legs moans are you saying
I'm good thank you I was assuming you
would assume you're good I like to think
myself as a good person
you probably conceal them these expanded
jizz that make him look thinner just
before we started recording you were
saying I probably wear a lot of layers
to make myself look more muscular yeah I
made an assumption about you right
before we recorded I did I did assume
some assuming things it seems plausible
I wish
oh he's dead
you got it honey that's a D card all
right so now I have to do this again on
kind of lower health pull your pistol
out yep I think this is a cutscene
unfortunately so I have to do it right
after yeah it's like if it's not hard
enough to kill this jerk-off now I have
to do it in four minutes
it's like how do I leave anyway do you
know hopefully just stops when you're
killing [ __ ]
all right so r2 is the name of the game
I even forget dodging both of them I
feel like it's both
I wish that counted as a hit right there
dude you don't have four minutes in this
with 327 come on come on come on come on
come on come on
what you doing I don't know [ __ ] up
I'm in trouble he's gonna hit me isn't
he yeah got me he got me got me okay I
think yeah use it not going well
sir okay oh [ __ ] I really thought I had
more room so I [ __ ] it up again I guess
I have to be farther away suck I got it
I got it I got it
okay got it oh I'm too early but jerk
I swear and doing it tell me I'm nuts
like I feel so it feels so right but
it's not happening here we go now too
late
[ __ ] what that was too early no I think
you gotta like shoot it before he I'm
almost out of bullets here we go I feel
it doesn't seem to work well I swear
people think I'm not mean this valve
specifically I'm obviously missing it I
mean you guys tell me this is the only
one I can make work come on give me a
[ __ ] little break just a little one
just a little break with a little break
am I done okay so you're not like
magnetizing to it I don't know I'm not
doing great
I will admit this I just don't know what
I'm doing wrong yet like I'm definitely
oh come on get in there you dick yeah I
don't know no not not going well for
Jill Valentine like what where am I I'm
doing our to just to be very clear for
the audience who must think I'm
absolutely stupid like I 100% I'm using
our - it's just
like I've done it before we were there
he did way more than this side that's
like the only one I can get to what I'm
not gonna die based on time you know
that yeah would you do differently I
thought much other switches and that's
how you do cool um so that one they
weren't ready yet like the green stuff
isn't ready yeah I don't know I don't
know what causes me to have no idea like
maybe I'm hitting him cool
it's not gonna hold seconds left huh
like I'm gonna die what I need to know
is how to get these other two this is
like the first time I feel like pretty
conflicted that I like I know my play
wasn't perfect but I'm not sure why the
handles aren't turning because I'm using
our too and it's not it's not
it must be my angle
you know like it's either my angle or
it's like I'm doing something wrong but
I I'm not getting any feedback besides
that sometimes it works and sometimes it
doesn't
it must look really frustrating like I'm
really frustrated but I I've had like
two weeks of non nemesis to refresh I'm
not mad anymore but I I honestly don't
know what's wrong yeah
do I need to be in front of it I don't
know I'm looking up just make sure
you're not doing anything like that like
maybe I have to be in front of it that's
the thing like I'm so confused have any
more bullets like Reggie bullets and
like I could like take a thing just for
like one more heal but I like I'm solo
in heels it makes me sad to do that you
could bring like like the acid rounds I
mean you could bring like you shouldn't
need to well no I mean like that's
stunning him I it's like you can keep
shooting him and stuff while he's
stunned or like right after your so you
don't still rely entirely on the spigots
but so I like bringing the hand gun
shoot the spigot when it starts hitting
a blaster just start pumping him full of
gene aids but won't I have like an end
battle or something where I'm gonna
totally need that yeah but no like oh my
remember yeah I mean you have a lot I
have this grenade launcher with four
grenades and it like I just hit him a
couple times I'm just like a little
busted honestly like obviously I'm doing
something wrong this is not intentional
but I don't know exactly what it is okay
so you're not hearing or eating anything
that would elude that I'm silly I might
just be a matter of when they said press
r2 I thought holding our
watch this hold r1 you test it on these
dudes hold r1 then press r2 doesn't our
to switch the target that you're looking
at I will kill all of you so I'm out of
[ __ ] [ __ ] I can't kill this stupid
thing oh yes I can no wait sorry what
were you saying doesn't like I thought
like there's a button you press when
you're aiming already that changes
targets maybe that's what they meant
press r2 while you're aiming you should
be able to do that that's not fair you
cheated I got hurt stupid ass I didn't
think they could hurt me on the stairs
cuz of that issue once before where I
totally evaded based on that exact
premise buns well it's not my finest
moment yeah all right cool I'm back baby
so change targets with l1 what
oh well that's not what we're talking
about though yeah yeah our two drawers
are - oh so hold our - then press l1 so
our two drawers it so r1 always targets
enemies are two hearts are all
targetable objects great but then you
can still press while your guns out to
change targets okay okay so r2 and then
I need to use l1 to determine which
spicket maybe yeah it goes between him
like maybe I need to be in a certain
draw weapon with our two and then oh
[ __ ] I'm maybe instead of holding it let
go and tap it cuz that and like it's an
auto aim thing like instead of holding
it and then using the directional pad to
aim hold it like press it and press R to
happen until it selects back
sorry press r2 and then tap l1 either
that or just tap r2 instead of holding
it like kept like if you tap it once
well I have to hold r1 to aim no you
don't are to you just draws the weapon
also toward all target are one's gonna
make you focus on an enemy ones I guess
I'm saying is to draw my weapon I have
to hit I have to hold down one of them
like I don't tap well I'm not saying tap
it saying like hold it and then like
cycle through objects with art - like
like you bring it up once I'll just go
saying hold r1 and then tap press r2 and
then like hold it but it's gonna go the
Nemesis soleko and then press it again
and hold it so it'll should cycle the
next target or try the r2 and then press
l1 to cycle through the targets alright
so I'll probably hold r2 and then use l1
to cycle but I wonder if she'll like
visually be like or if it's just like
implied no no
these are things I don't know yeah
gotten by without them this far well
it's finished it's been quite a struggle
these last few episodes I'll tell you
that right now I just don't want to have
another nemesis episode where I spend
the 1 so not killing the nemesis I think
is my fear because I [ __ ] hated that
episode me too it really took a toll on
me mentally all right so our to use l1
to switch shoot man
that's what this is saying like our l1
changes targets ok that might help and I
got 4 minutes not even three-and-a-half
minutes like they wouldn't give you such
a short amount of time if they didn't
think you could do it quickly
right so where am I what am I supposed
to do in those 4 minutes my supposed to
go back there to this blinky light
that's the problem what if I kill him
I got like 10 seconds left and I'm like
what do I do and you're like I don't
know I got like such limited time I
assume it's hitting that red button that
seems reasonable
such a short time all right let's do it
[Music]
I'm gonna run past him oh I ran the
wrong way no problem I got it nice
get out of there what happened acid
misses him yeah but would you use yeah
see that just snaps so yeah but it's not
snapping to the right thing see that I
don't know if you can tell oh my god
Jesus but it didn't snap to the right
thing do you know what I mean like it's
only snapping to him I'm watching it
happen
you're pressing our tuna Tower one so I
feel like I'm not in the right spot is
how I feel
yes see she's only snapping to know that
try that what it's going it's going to
the spigot now I'm doing that myself huh
he's whipping me from my father shoot
him grenades now oh okay yeah that's
smart you might only have time for one
yeah that probably wasn't smart already
on caution
run from the night one okay oh [ __ ] I
[ __ ] up I'm in trouble
I think he's gonna drop something but
you pick up afterward you're not the
time around that's the problem
Tara
like I'm I'm not crazy you're dodging
measly I was this is the only one but he
has to wit me anyway he's walked into a
few times an [ __ ]
like how hurt is he and like I'm running
at a time I just drew Nate I'm always
there
[ __ ] you you dick
okay okay okay here we go here we go oh
yeah now run around it it's gonna work
out nice we dead hopefully so go up you
should have dropped something I think
yeah there you go that's on the other
side you've got plenty of weight it
what's on the other side the keycard
alright you got a minute 45 you're fine
other side of this pile what's oh no I
ain't married you got sorry yes I don't
wanna do to get home this way I know I
do it again go around okay come back
okay try that
gimme gimme-gimme-gimme I don't know
what you're doing I think yours leaving
I don't know again that's a lot more
time than you feel like don't let the
alarm it what don't let her arm you
don't do that what you use on that
imagine if I did it and then it like
kept going down like that you so happy
you beat him just kidding you don't
fight him again right now no I
just piles of bodies yes
stupid Oh No
don't [ __ ] with me I'm not alright well
yeah well I don't know oh there's a safe
room nearby you should say oh god please
where dink you might leave that one
great so you got the car key I'm
assuming that's what you're using them
okay so out of this hallway to the right
in into that same room is what you're
saying yeah okay that sounds good
so there's azzam as soon as I leave this
room I have no health so I need be very
careful should I equip something I
almost want to quit shot just to like
not [ __ ] around you know why is this
music so intense it's like toward the
end of games they always do that but I'm
not on a time limit you should you
should Oh
pull your shotgun out at the very least
[ __ ] no come back and come back and
shoot them yeah I'm working on it
nice you're fine oh I should do that
headshot thing yeah as long as you're
just not dying you're fine Oh where's
your head your skull is in my butt
whew that was close one they kind of
like your eyeballs in my butt all right
okay so all the way to the right how
many shot ease do I have two plus one
equals go on the answer was three Mike
sorry what
I know you're saying okay sorry I know
I'm map crazy right now I just don't
wanna make a mistake that's right take a
right it's on my left that makes sense
save save save save save save all your
[ __ ] oh is this it I mean this music is
leading me to believe so you know it's
coming up you don't like crazy though
like I actually don't think I've almost
any health which is such a bummer I have
not done a great job at surviving got a
bunch alright okay yeah but don't don't
overwrite you're making stuff no what is
it gonna say cuz I can make stuff first
and then say that way I don't to make it
every time I'm just saying no matter
what don't overwrite the last save yeah
got it okay so do you think I should
make stuff first okay so what do you
want to make probably freeze rounds okay
um let me think to remember how to do
that no all right well I'd rather not
screw that up
I think it's si si si and you make si by
mixing a and B let's get a bunch of a
and B
so funny we've done this before but you
know it's really stressful yeah I need
that but not while I'm making things
because like what I can do is I can
combine three A's and I can combine
three B's and then make a super B I have
twenty fries rounds if you believe it
we've done great work
I'm sure that's how you do it right
combined days combined bees combine
those and you get a see yeah right
wait yeah I think so hey wait like a
combine with another a and then you
combine these oh no I don't think so I
did a mistake was it a and B it was a
and B together and then you kind of just
went ahead and did it I think you're
fine anyway because I don't think you
like necessarily it's like an
environmental thing to kill a fire
I'm just gonna go ahead and do it she
says while there's music I did tell your
weight oh my god just don't overwrite
that last save I don't think you'll need
them
you bring the Magnum bring your other
freezers goddamn bullets thank you way
too many regular grenades no I could
make regular grenades how do you make
grenade go down go near inventory I
thought you had some grenades oh right
I have 2020 freeze rounds there oh I
have regular grenades and then I have
2020 ground be plenty and then I have a
magnum and I have six Magnum bullets
yeah we're fine we got this yeah wait I
think you can make stuff winter grenades
to make them freeze
oh yeah you can yeah but what is it uh I
don't know why don't we just look at my
all that you can though you need to see
to mix it up and you can't make sense
cuz you just have to age you seem like
you'll be fine alright
should I not have a handgun or a shotgun
probably don't need a shotgun right yeah
oh I need that grenade launcher Oh
imagine if I cut my hand on the animal
if I showed up no I want that actually
imagine if I showed up without the
grenade out the grenade launcher
hopefully you probably find a few guys
on the way but hopefully just died you
use the shotgun enough no way I thought
your get rid of shotgun taking the
handgun well you should I can make a lot
of shotgun shells now I'm so stupid I'm
very disappointed in myself I'd have
made so many things and here we are
ruined by my own impatience classic
merry maneuver alright I'm not
overriding our old save just in case
[ __ ] goes super bad okay
I'm gonna use an ink ribbon here we go
maybe should bring the shotgun okay I'm
going to save over 19 okay you want me
to take the shotgun instead of because I
can make more shotgun shells
sure yeah instead of a handgun yeah I
could do that that's not a problem
especially now that I [ __ ] up so so
severely yeah bless my stupid soul oh my
god
get rid of one other thing to get the
other shotgun shells in here Oh what do
you mean I have a free space man you
don't have anything else to make oh I
need to bring a shotgun dum-dum
okay you don't have the grenade launcher
buddy right now just say you know yes of
course I would just get rid of those
grenades honestly or those magnum rounds
what do you think is more powerful
grenades or magnum rounds I don't
I think magnum rounds maybe get rid of
regular grenades freeze rounds are
better than I can put freeze rounds in
my grenade launcher which I should do
yeah I hope this is no no hold on hold
on hold on hold on all right don't do
that don't do that put the grenade
rounds in the grenade launcher but don't
we like freeze rounds more anyway yeah
but yeah yeah yeah
oh no let's be real here yeah put a free
round end then just don't worry and just
have the backups I don't think you're
gonna be twenty of them oh yeah we whoa
it holds twenty oh [ __ ] it's weird he's
weird so so I could bring him now sure
or I could bring something else
no it's bring grenades okay sorry I'm
panicking
it was a scary time for me and I [ __ ]
up a very important thing I can't
believe I did that
I really disappointed in myself Effie
okay all right I'm ready I think
come on Mary get it together here we go
feelin it how are you feeling pretty
good it I mean I don't think you're like
totally at the end but what I feel like
what you're close to you
prep me for the end all right where am I
going south or Noth
I think South back because you're going
back to the entrance but try the
northern or anywhere just to get user
car key get rid of it if that is a car
key door I don't remember anymore oh no
this is a battery operated oh I got it
well let me wait you gonna go in sure I
hope it's a Frick ton of help
Oh mamacita
is there anything else
I'm just quietly observing get out of
here
my snare is health the other way
I have a tiny plastic card sweet no that
was misleading okay it must be a
different tiny plastic card
yeah maybe go back down you saw there
later goat stuck to the south door
you've got it
I hate this game like I like it but I
hate how it makes me feel which is just
upset yep all the time forever upset
alright so left
yeah it's pretty stressful they've done
a great job of making me upset all the
time me too
all right left all the way down this is
it oh okay
you should probably just kill them hey
mm-hmm
a little far nice get some herbs up
there too looks like it might be seen
actually might not have room that's the
problem
different for one you can combine those
two and I get the other one combined
greens yeah
why would you do that you can combine
greens what does it do thanks I thought
it was only green and are you sure
I didn't think combining a green and a
green did they don't have any other Reds
to combine I mean yeah it's just gonna
make it it's just saving room you don't
have I gonna you know you can get both
Oh shet you're gonna need to what get
rid of something is you're gonna need
like a exit key I've go see what it is
do we can figure out worst-case scenario
just use that green herb I probably will
go through one at that point because
everything hurts me now and in shock
hey hey oh no what'd you call me
weboth that Carla stop having the last
chopper that's right Carlos it's gonna
be a timer on the last fight to the
missile no fantastique
so am I being timed right now
[Music]
no I might not start until a warning
missile attack
but six yeah just go now the light okay
I guess there you go nothing else I can
do unless you think there's something
else in this room you can I mean just
makes me make mistakes cuz then I'm like
huh say bah am I in a safe room yeah but
I think you have everything you need but
I still think we should say it's just a
do I have everything
do you feel very good about my chances
say yes sure
great cool let's do it guys gonna wake
up awesome that that guy's alive looks
like oh they're all gonna wake up what
do you mean okay
hurry missiles coming oh right the
missile no right that giant missile that
could melt my body okay scope out the
area great unless your cartography
habits are not shown shot Specter your
[ __ ] face
if the worm comes after me now I'm gonna
be mad how you killed a member you
electrocuted it apparently what I've
learned in these games is nothing ever
dies there's a lesson to be learned I so
get a grenade look but also yes so I'm
taking a right well I can't get through
it yet I can't get through
it's red I couldn't save why would they
let me save me you're probably gonna try
that door out sorry I don't know where I
am
okay that was at the door this power is
going outside it cannot be unlocked now
okay so I need to power it a Power
Distribution unit that's not working now
great cool this is going well about down
here little one I guess it's yellow what
machines do not show
there's not enough power to activate the
system yeah go to one I guess it was
yellow as opposed to red like the other
three Oh
- do you know do you know we're back
toward the first door you came in that
makes more sense
so you have to be pushing these in while
you're neither there's a tire right
that's a tyrant holy [ __ ]
oh that's crazy that's a tyrant from
it's just it's not doing anything you
got to walk up against you gotta push up
against it
you mean to push it yeah that's what you
just did two three almost like come up
to this bottom wall of that green thing
push it push it forever
no like you push it into one got it
sorry Oh for [ __ ] sake lady it's gonna
cause problems I can tell shut oh my
gosh pretty much for my room to shoot
him as often as you can but mainly focus
on avoiding him and putting the
batteries in wait so you actually don't
want me to do anything can I not kill
him yeah you can shoot I said shoot him
but also like put in the in the
batteries I did a bad job go for two I
guess right now while he's back here
it's three can I do I have to do them in
order I would I think so yeah
where's two actually don't know where
two is I see one opposite side of one
past three nice where oh it's up top and
then over to the left
[ __ ]
where's how do you get up top push that
[ __ ] in got it no problem nice and I go
for three okay okay oh you did
yeah you should be good pushing this in
and I think yours gonna to go up to that
press oh is he in the deaf rare now
don't ya I don't fire at lessons in it
don't wait where is he he's in front of
right now but by the time you fire it
I can we honestly
oh yeah shoot it shoot it shoot is that
it I don't know where's that controls I
thought that was the computer hi we'll
wait for your command because I'm
actually a little freaked out in fact I
actually I'm afraid he's gonna kill me
because I'm on caution oh it's like
counting down the death rate yeah okay
so I just should play just to avoid him
okay I think
Oh God
oh [ __ ] all right I don't know if he's
in front of it right now
oh go back toward it to learn it up okay
a feeling once he gets hit by it start
using getting it back up - yeah I'm
working on it I'm working on it
let me just cross what I you just so we
it didn't work
Oh got you no no no okay so okay so now
you got a whole circle to run through
and then you want to learn into here
next time so it's much easier just do
what you did okay all right okay get out
of there it's gonna shoot again oh it
sounded it's firing twice you might have
to push in the batteries again there I
don't think you're gonna hit him this
time
comeget don't know it is you don't the
push him in against sweet you said to
lure him into that tunnel no don't go
too far he's gonna come back this way
you hit him go [ __ ] them up with
grenades yeah sorry I just get him to
come this way but I don't let him shoot
you that said all right the acid he's
[ __ ] [ __ ] he's really I mean yeah Brett
no don't try this one just get the next
one he's slow enough that
don't go too far you but I don't wanna
be in the past you have plenty of time
you're not luring him you're just
running to the outside of the circle
again no idea these are the questions
there you go
you're gonna miss them don't be afraid
to heal yes but once this hits on me the
[ __ ]
no I don't you know yet that'd be green
and blue is only worth one anyway
yeah now [ __ ] them out okay wait I
should feel don't you think I should
yeah use that and then use grenades on
use grenade equip yeah
wait shoot him oh I unequipped it my
life looks like he's not stun anymore
just let it be shoot him again I know
you should be am I hit him
yeah wait hold on let's not get ahead of
ourselves
I'm very excited how much time you have
left okay so I remember this let's hope
he's sweet god I hope he's dead oh wait
why those batteries but that's an
unnecessary go through the door then I
guess wait go through the door go
through the dark go through the dark
okay I just said wait why did the door
to make a noise cuz it it's no still
alive you got do it again no that's a
stupid game oh no just evacuate you
could probably be right now you're just
low on time evacuate the missile is
getting weirdly you might alright so you
might have had time to kill him I don't
want to risk that because you're saving
so long ago
I wonder what happens you just it's a
different ending I think
I think I mean it would be nice to kill
away
no I want to get out of this hellhole
the most upsetting game
[Music]
stores my penis no Senate I won't
actually will not believe it until I see
the credit no God
dodge it Carlos
there's the noob that destroyed wrecking
city I feel like that should also kill
us yeah probably would
[Music]
I think a new boredom
[Music]
it's a new proof copter I guess we could
do another episode where you just kill
it
because I don't think it takes too long
rather unfortunate turn event says the
newscasts are about a new council it was
rather unfortunate let's see what
happens because the nuke should have
killed the monster it's better than 100
billion that's correct
that's a bigger number my
[Music]
oh I just feel like I could put this
game behind me I feel so good mm-hmm
what'd you think of the game overall I
think it was one of the most stressful
upsetting games I've ever played in my
life I think it's the hardest of the
three and I still think that number one
is my favorite
number one is so good yeah
it's so good number two is very good and
I think this is also very good but did
those have like a Barry Manilow credit
song I think so I think was a calming
credits turn sweet and then like we have
this a file from that so maybe one day
where a lot of cheap moments in that
game where it kind of doesn't respect
your progress like 1 & 2 it was usually
your photos
whereas this seems like it didn't care
okay so on to yours
I've never played resin before hey we're
we're on to the yeah people are asking
about Cove Veronica and like zero and
those we're gonna go through the number
titles right now but again no promises
but maybe we'll go back to the plan is
to do them all man I mean it's just that
we wanted to do numbers first because
seven is common like it is
we will probably it's like right there I
guarantee that at least at the games but
often we would probably have seven in
our hands before we beat four yeah
whatever we'll play five so up sweet
yeah greatest wait do you want to look
post-credits just in case just in case
sure doesn't kick but sometimes they put
a little sneaky sneaky nemesis don't
ruin it for yourself nothing just said
city what it looks like now I'm fine
with that
sweet that's like 50 16 hours I got now
are you that surprised that's that's
pretty fitting all right I'm stopping
the recording on that No